so I I got in trouble a few weeks ago
for pointing out or even just hosting a
woman for an interview who pointed out
that
pornography is turning a lot of people
trans
and Media Matters or my publicists over
there mocked me for this and criticized
me for this and a lot of liberals have
mocked and criticized this idea that
pornography addiction to pornography
increasingly weird pornography is
largely responsible for turning lots of
otherwise basically normal people trans
and
I you know I hate to say I told you so
the two guys who made The Matrix
the Wachowski brothers
they both went trans which is kind of
strange that two brothers around the
same time would go trans there's a video
now circulating it's been dug up of one
of the Wachowski Brothers Andy Wachowski
explaining
that I'm totally right
to be honest like for me the the people
that I saw the first images that really
struck a chord with me were you know
trans women in pornography and um
there was something that
um unlocked and my brain
that I saw these uh wonderful Fearless
performers
um becoming these um becoming desirable
and
I in my head I could take the leap where
I felt like well may if I could be
desirable then maybe I could be loved
and for me that's like one of the keys
that trans people have to like struggle
through you know will somebody love me
and
so yeah that's that's my answer Nick
Adams it's an excellent answer Lily
Wachowski
so Andy now goes by Lily
what he described as his experience is
one of the most prominent trans
identifying people in America is exactly
what I said happened for which I was
criticized by all the libs
but of course that happens what did
Wachowski say
he said I was watching this kind of
weird porn so I was going down a rabbit
hole and then something got unlocked in
my brain
and I viewed myself differently
and I cultivated a new kind of Desire
a a new vision of how I desired even to
be desirable
to others
and then I viewed myself as a woman
yeah I think that happens for a lot of
people
the only ones talking about this are the
feminists and the actual conservatives
the squishes and the libs and the center
right and the center left and the people
in the middle they refuse to acknowledge
that
porn and depravity and vice
are largely responsible for the spread
of the transgender identity and ideology
but this is how desire is formed
desire is not just something that you're
born with and it remains exactly the
same over time it's not merely something
that pops up one day and now you've got
this desire for the rest of your life
desire is a complex interplay of aspects
of your nature and aspects of your
acculturation that develop and deepen or
they lessen over time the scientific
jargon for this always involves neural
pathways
and I don't mean to mock the scientific
jargon too much if that helps you to see
what the phenomenon is then that's great
but people will say well look if you if
you're a big fat guy and whenever you're
feeling a little down or anxious or
bored or so you go eat an ice cream pop
then you're going to deepen the neural
Pathways you're going to deepen the the
reward mechanism
and so whenever you start to feel that
way you're going to eat the ice cream
pop and it's going to make you fatter
but it's going to be harder to break
that but you could you could make the
same kind of observation about a heroin
addict you can make the same observation
about a pornography addict you could
make the same observation about anybody
engaging in any kind of
habitual behavior that is how desire is
formed right now go to geniusell.com did
you know our friends at genucel have
upgraded their most popular package to
feature their top selling deep firming
vitamin C serum plus Ultra retinol
moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative did you know that
right now you can take advantage of this
limited time package upgrade for seventy
seven zero percent off why waste time
and money to go get work done to your
face when you can get geniusell skin
care shipped right to your door here's a
geniusell.com review from Robert in
blessing Texas quote I purchased genucel
as a gift for my girlfriend she said she
saw the results so fast her skin is
noticeably softer and smoother I can see
and feel a difference too she was
already beautiful and geniusell has made
her more beautiful geniuselle's secret
is a family recipe for over 20 years
that makes it safer all skin types and
perfect for both men and women you might
think that it's only women buying this
turns out actually probably slightly
more men than women I also love the
founder a compounding pharmacist he
makes it in small batches he's a
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream it's just a great guy
great company great product go to
geniusell.com's most popular package for
seventy seven zero percent off featuring
both jsl's Ultra retinol and Geniuses
Firming Serum get a complimentary spot
essential specs with every package order
plus free upgrade to priorityshipping
geniusell.com
Knowles the reason the science jargon is
not all that persuasive is because we're
not just bodies we're not just bags of
chemicals and brains inside a skeleton
but we're body and soul and so the way
that I think is simpler and more precise
to talk about it is is that this is how
our desires
are formed and that's exactly the kind
of language that Wachowski is using so
on the one side of transgender
observations you've got Michael Knowles
and one of the most prominent
transvestites in America
and the people who say we're wrong are a
bunch of Libs over Media Matters can you
imagine can you imagine but that's
obviously
I think we're on the right side of that
speaking of Desire
got a great story a very rare great
story in the news that has nothing to do
with weird sex stuff has nothing to do
with immigration has nothing to do with
the Democrats destroying our culture
this is just a great story
is a 45 year old high school custodian
and part-time Barber
who just earned his
high school diploma
this is a guy I saw this story pop up
local news story
45 year old Elmo de Silva this was
reported by Atlanta news first
his custodian for the Indian Creek
Elementary School in Clarkston
and he just joined over 40 other adults
who got their High School diplomas
during a recent ceremony he said
it wasn't easy it was a struggle for a
while and to achieve and get through it
and looking back I'm very proud
this guy had to drop out of high school
to take care of his younger brothers
now all these years later he's gone back
gotten his high school diploma I think
it's great big congratulations to that
guy and the political lesson to take and
the personal lesson for all of us is
a reminder
that it is never too late to improve
yourself
we are often tempted to think oh it's
too late I can't fix my situation my
family situation
my professional situation my male
education
my vice my bad habits my addictions my
it's just too light it's too far gone
you know old dog ain't gonna change its
spots
and and people are tempted to think this
way from the time they're five years old
we're always tempted to think this way
but it's just not true it's never too
late Jeremy
the god king Jeremy boring just made
this point on Twitter today on a fairly
unrelated topic he said that it's never
too late until it is until you're going
into the ground it's not too late so you
you can improve yourself and a lot of
people think
that in our culture which is so depraved
it's got just such
Madness and addiction all around her in
the throes of the worst opioid crisis
ever we've got the average life
expectancy decreasing these of deaths of
Despair obviously all the weird sex
stuff going on uh family breakdown
loneliness epidemic
it's very easy to think oh well it's
just it's all too far gone there's no
way we can ever yes you can you can over
the way you overcome it one is to turn
to God and accept God's grace and then
to cooperate with that Grace and just
take it one day at a time
and you just go back to that classroom
for one day and then you go back the
next day and you go back the next day
and you keep doing your job and guess
what after a while you've got a high
school diploma after a while you've
cured that addiction after or greatly
abated the addiction after a while
you've grown in virtue after a while
it's not too late
you're a human being with reason and
will you can do a lot I'm glad you like
that clip now need you to subscribe ring
that Bell get all the notifications for
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel see
you next time